we went to the public and asked them if
I am praying Salah would they stand
there protecting me let's see what
happened but before we go brothers and
sisters inshallah it is the best 10 days
of the years to pan all the brothers and
sisters the rewards are immense now they
were there standing to see if they will
help me pray however you can brothers
and sisters help teach someone to pray
for the first time ever Surah fatih
imagine you are the reason somebody
learns how to do record how to do such
that how to memorize go to the link in
the description box and help our
organization which is a charity to help
teach New Rivers and born Muslims how to
pray
so guys I am in Camden Town we're gonna
do a social experiment where I go to
people and ask them to keep a lookout
while I pray Salah lest he was going to
help me who's going to ignore me and
whoever keeps an eye they will get to
win one of these prizes in trouble
sorry mate have you got two minutes
sorry guys can you do me a quick favor
I'm so sorry I just need to pray I'm
just wondering
sorry brother have you got two minutes
beautiful
foreign
I'm gonna pray I just needed to keep
something
excuse me sir sorry can I just ask you a
question I'm just I just need to quickly
pray can you keep it nice so nobody
tries to attack me
oh
hiding Bubba have you got two minutes
[Applause]
sorry guys I'm just wondering I'm not
feeling anything I'm not saying anything
I know okay so you guys want to talk to
me
what
sorry bro I'm not saying anything
sorry sorry mate I just quickly need to
pray on my Muslim can you just keep an
eye onto it huh
excuse me sir sorry I just need to pray
I don't need any money can you keep an
eye so nobody attacks me it's okay
sorry Papa sorry I'm a Muslim I need to
pray I'm just wondering can you keep an
eye so somebody doesn't attack me while
I pray for me yeah I'm just gonna pray
that is it okay yeah I'm just gonna
chill because I don't want to get I want
to try attacking you yeah what's your
name I mean just give me I'm just gonna
I'm gonna be like two and a half minutes
so basically I just need to pray and I'm
just scared someone will try to hit me
can you just keep an eye on somebody I'm
just gonna be here No One's Gonna touch
you come on chill dude do you mind yeah
you'll find this baby keep an eye out
sorry no I'm just gonna put it here it's
gonna be two minutes man I really
appreciate it because my good attack man
yeah yeah thank you much appreciate it
can you guys keep an eye so I don't get
attacked I could
you manufacture where are you where are
you guys
yeah yeah yeah I'll just do two and a
half minutes yeah
yeah do you mind like somewhere maybe
just near the Lamppost
yeah sorry man I appreciate it man sorry
guys
you guys from here
today we're just outside London oh okay
all right yeah yeah I'll just need two
and a half minutes I really appreciate
it man
what's that
[Music]
oh man I really appreciate it man thank
you man you didn't you didn't have to do
that no no what's your name
are you are you are you Christian Chris
really yeah
thank you very much man I really
appreciate it man what's your name Abby
where you from Germany oh you're from
Germany okay it's your girlfriend
oh classmate okay you live in London no
no okay it's just a classroom okay I
really appreciate him why did you you
didn't have to do it
no no no no
all right come on come I'm gonna give
you a gift man I'm too I really
appreciate it it's an experiment but you
know what I just really want to know I'm
going to give you free Apple airports
what what phone do you have uh
iPhone yeah okay I've got airports brand
new
you did this because you didn't have to
and I'm dressed up like this I mean you
could have been like but you stood there
like what made you do that you know just
helping a guy out okay you don't want
the airports man are you sure I
appreciate what's your name Jimmy Jimmy
no no no no no this is airports they're
brand new what phone you gotta know bro
you know
what phone you got I lost like I lost my
left
[Music]
no no
there we go warranty everything there
you go guys I appreciate man you know
why because
uh yeah and I appreciate it because you
know as Muslims you know sometimes you
know we pray on the streets get attacked
Etc but you didn't have to and I
appreciate my friends are Muslim bro
really me personally bro I'm a Christian
but yeah I I also read Quran yeah I know
a lot of a lot of yeah that's good man
I'm really happy for you I appreciate
you man look after yourself thank you
sister thank you very much and that's it
any words you want to say to people oh
is it for YouTubers YouTube YouTube yeah
I'm a YouTuber
Jones
okay and yeah thank him I really
appreciate it man take care of yourself
take care thank you very much
I really appreciate it man thank you
very much
cool thank you man you guys you guys not
for around here
I appreciate it man you know some people
would have this perception but just
because you guys came out the pub you
know but it's a social experiment
uh there's a camera there
um we'll give a gift for you guys
um airports
okay
we're gonna give a little message
it's been
no you know what I really appreciate it
man you know why because people have
this perception you know I get I get
judged the way I dress I don't usually
dress up like I've got caption balls
but the thing is even though people
people judge people like you you in the
past they'll think you'll be probably
the last person that would ever stand
here and just keep God if someone is I
felt bad having my points besides
did you do that because I appreciate it
I appreciate it man I mean any but guys
as you can see we've got this two lovely
gentlemen you guys married girlfriends
uh
you're watching I'm going to give my
YouTube channel here you've got some
good lads we all look after them yeah
okay thank you very much guys enjoy
yourself take care my name is Ali Dao on
YouTube the video will come out next
week if you want to watch it yeah yeah
yeah my name is
stick it in no problem you don't ever
judge a book by its cover guys guys I'm
in front of the club what I'm about to
say is not made up imagine you watch
this video and donate 100 pounds for 10
salamats and from 10 of them only one
just comes to the Kaaba and praise all
their Salah for four days praise the
janaza praise the jumma praise that
praise all their five salons every
single Salah is equivalent to a hundred
thousand and guess who gets a reward
literally taught them how to pray by
donating this guided prayer mat so do
not miss on this reward click the button
or the link and donate now